Mission: Impossible Fallout runs for an amazing
147 minutes and is jam-packed with awesome
action scenes and stunning moments, but there
were even more great scenes cut from the final
movie.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'm revealing the top 10
deleted and censored scenes you never got
to see in Mission: Impossible 6, including
White Widow in Kashmir, fake trailer shots,
and helicopter near-collisions.
Watch out for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie, or add this video to your Water
Later playlist and come back when you're ready.
One scene from the trailers which fans were
really hoping to see but which didn't make
it into the final movie was where Ethan's
helicopter was going full pelt into an on-coming
truck on a forest road.
This scene would have appeared during the
already-packed helicopter chase sequence between
Ethan and Henry Cavill's Walker, and I think
could have been during one of the moments
where Ethan's chopper was spiralling out of
control.
Given how close the chopper and truck come
to colliding, I'd have love to have seen how
Ethan got himself out of this one!
In the movie, after the HALO jump in Paris,
we see Cruise and Cavill land on the roof
of the Grand Palais, but a further stunt sequence
filmed inside the Palais was cut.
The deleted scene featured Cruise swinging
from a rope over the crowd and was rejected
by writer-director Christopher McQuarrie as,
although it looked pretty cool, the film was
already running long and it wasn't necessary
for the story.
While the movie gives us a number of big fight
scenes inside the Grand Palais, another smaller
one that happened outside the venue was given
the chop.
In the final film, after Ethan and White Widow
exit the building, next thing we know they're
in the back of a car together.
But there's a deleted scene before that car
ride where Ethan gets into a fight with White
Widow's brother Zola and smashes his head
against a car, which actually left actor Frederick
Schmidt with a black eye!
I imagine this moment was ditched in the editing
room as it didn't move the plot forward but
merely reinforced the animosity we'd already
witnessed earlier when Zola warned Ethan not
to touch his sister.
Actress Vanessa Kirby told MTV that the car
ride with White Widow and Ethan was part of
a much longer and now deleted scene where,
in her words, "things got a bit fruity" between
them.
In the cut scene, White Widow talked about
how she enjoyed having blood on her dress
from the knife fight earlier in the Palais.
This deleted scene would have further played
up the flirtation between her and Ethan, and
would also have been a call-back to the car
ride that Ethan took with Max in the first
Mission: Impossible movie.
In case you missed it, Max was revealed to
be White Widow's mother in this film, and
I explain that in more detail in my Mission:
Impossible 6 Connections and Ending video.
This gorgeous scene of Ethan, White Widow
and Walker marching through a hall of mirrors
was in the movie, however, an alternate shot
of Ethan and Ilsa walking down the hallway
was never used.
McQuarrie has said that shot of Tom Cruise
and Rebecca Ferguson was never meant to be
in the movie and was specifically filmed as
something cool for the trailers.
There was also a big fight scene with Isla
cut from the film, and hopefully we'll get
more details on that on the Blu-ray.
The trailers also teased numerous shots from
the final act set in Kashmir which never made
it into the final film.
Some of those shots hint at some pretty dark
moments with Ethan, Ilsa, Benji and Luther
encountering murdered soldiers and aid workers
at a border checkpoint.
The scene seems to go on with Ethan approaching
the door to a bunker, opening it and descending
some stairs where I suspect he would have
discovered further horrors.
It's unclear whether the murders they discover
are the actions of Walker or Solomon Lane.
Some Indian viewers suspect these specific
border scenes might have been cut to avoid
controversy in India as the Kashmir region
which geographically spans India, Pakistan
and China is one of the most militarised areas
of the world and has long-running border and
separatist conflicts.
In fact, Mission: Impossible Fallout has already
been censored by India's film classification
board.
All mentions of Kashmir have been cut from
the Indian release of the movie, including
dialogue, the title card that comes on screen
when the region first appears, and other scenes
have also been trimmed.
Director Christopher McQuarrie has said that
any deleted trailer scenes were simply cut
because the movie was too long, which sounds
perfectly reasonable given the film's long
run-time; though I do wonder if in this instance
political considerations also played a part.
There's some curious behind-the-scenes footage
of White Widow actress Vanessa Kirby on the
set in New Zealand where the Kashmir scenes
were filmed.
White Widow never appeared in Kashmir in the
final film, so I wonder whether there was
originally a story where the handover of Solomon
Lane that she brokered was going to take place
there.
One of the more meta moments in Fallout comes
when Henry Cavill's Walker angrily asks Solomon
Lane, "why do you have to make everything
so complicated?"
Originally, McQuarrie planned for this line
to be part of a much longer segment where
everything in the movie was explained; Walker's
backstory, what had happened to the plutonium,
and so on.
But test audiences hated it and thought it
was tedious, so it was cut.
I can understand why this exposition was removed,
as fans enjoy the Mission: Impossible movies
not only for their incredible action scenes
but also for their twists and turns.
These work best when the audience isn't too
confused, but doesn't know everything that's
going on and so it's about getting that balance
right.
Curiously absent from the IMF team this time
around after having appeared in the previous
two movies was Jeremy Renner's William Brandt.
In an interview with Digital Spy, McQuarrie
explained that "when the movie started, we
didn't really have a screenplay, so it was
very difficult for us to say who would be
in the movie for how long and on what days,
and [Renner] had a commitment to Marvel."
"If we had a finished script, we would have
been able to say, 'Yes, this will work and
we can let you go for this time', but there
was just no predicting what those roles were
going to turn out to be."
"It was just an unfortunate case of bad timing."
Admittedly, Renner's role in Rogue Nation
was scaled back to a smaller supporting part
than the one he had when he started the franchise
in Ghost Protocol, so it seems natural he
would have given priority to Marvel, and,
of course, he'd obviously have to honour the
contract he signed with them.
However, the worst part is, as Marvel fans
know, that Hawkeye never even appeared in
Avengers: Infinity War!
So, instead of appearing in two of the biggest
films of 2018, Renner played tag with Jon
Hamm, Ed Helms, Hannibal Buress, and Jake
Johnson instead.
Avengers 4 did shoot back-to-back with Infinity
War though, so hopefully he does have a decent
part in that movie.
And, assuming Renner does want to return,
I think we'll see Brandt back in Mission:
Impossible 7.
Speaking of which, although I feel Fallout
positioned CIA boss Erica Sloan as the likely
successor to Hunley, Brandt did work closely
with Hunley in Rogue Nation, so it's possible
he could take over as the IMF's new Secretary.
Though that probably wouldn't be the most
interesting role for his character and might
be disappointing to fans who'd like to see
him return to active duty.
A funny trailer moment was cut from the scene
when Benji, Ethan and Luther were waiting
to make the plutonium trade.
"This is a bad idea."
"Is it ever a good one?"
So, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been in the film?
And where does Fallout rank on your list of
favourite Mission: Impossible movies?
Let me know in the comments below.
Tap left to discover all the ways Fallout
connects with the other movies plus how it
sets up MI7 or tap right for my full movie
deleted scenes playlist.
If you enjoyed this video, I always appreciate
a thumbs-up and a share.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!